every human being has a tendency to
wonder is the grass greener on the other
side and what Hollywood has done is
built an entire sub-industry of telling
women yes it is actually go to the other
side go check it out no it's gonna be
great you're gonna love your time over
there and then you end up uh Divorced
with a broken family or with a person
who actually doesn't treat you very well
and this isn't addressed and we just
keep churning out media that's horribly
irresponsible it should just be like the
day after she gets the the hometown hero
guy and she leaves her snooty
businessman fiance he like wakes up and
he's like I think you should probably go
and she's like what do you mean I
thought we were having something's like
no I was just saying that so that you'd
sleep with me you can leave now but